Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Si repentinamente, los insectos
aumentaran mucho en tamaño,
y decidieran declararnos la guerra,
sin dudas los humanos perderíamos.
Seríamos aniquilados por
su superioridad numérica.
Se estima que hay 10 trillones
de insectos en el planeta.
Eso es un 1 seguido por 19 ceros.
En comparación con nuestra población
de unos 7000 millones,
hay 1000 millones de estos
invertebrados por cada humano.
Las cifras a nivel de especie
son impresionantes también.
Existen más de 60 000 especies
de vertebrados en el planeta.
Pero se conoce un millón
de especies de insectos,
y muchas otras que
no han sido catalogadas.
De hecho, estas criaturas son un 75 %
de todos los animales del planeta.
¿Cuál es el secreto de su éxito?
El número elevado de insectos
se debe a muchas cosas
que juntas los hacen las criaturas
más adaptables y resistentes,
en particular su impresionante
capacidad de reproducción.
La descendencia de muchas especies
a lo largo de sus vidas es numerosa.
La mayoría morirá,
pero una cantidad más que suficiente
sobrevivirá para reproducirse.
Las crías maduran muy de prisa,
por lo que el ciclo reproductivo
se reanuda rápidamente
y tiene lugar varias veces
cada poco tiempo.
Estas cifras significan
que, como clase,
la diversidad genética de
los insectos es enorme.
La riqueza de la información
genética de estas especies
les proporciona lo necesario
para adaptarse y prosperar
en muchos entornos
en todo el planeta.
Incluso entornos de los más extremos:
los escarabajos de la corteza
pueden vivir a -40 ºC,
las hormigas del desierto del Sahara
pueden aventurarse
con temperaturas superficiales de 70 ºC
y algunos abejorros pueden sobrevivir
a 5500 metros sobre el nivel del mar.
Los exoesqueletos de insectos
también hacen de armadura corporal,
que los protegen del mundo exterior
y les permite sobrevivir en hábitats
donde otras criaturas no resisten.
Incluso su tamaño pequeño,
que puede parecer una desventaja,
es algo que usan a su favor.
La mayoría de las especies
son tan diminutas
que millones de insectos pueden
compartir un espacio pequeño,
y disponer de todos
los recursos existentes.
Pueden ocupar varios cientos de
nichos en todos los ecosistemas.
Algunos insectos se alimentan
de raíces, tallos, hojas,
semillas, polen y néctar
de plantas específicas.
Otros, como las avispas,
capturan insectos vivos
y paralizan a sus víctimas
para depositar huevos dentro de estas.
Cuando sus larvas eclosionan,
se alimentan de las víctimas.
Los mosquitos y las moscas que
pican se alimentan de sangre,
y aprovechan este recurso inusual
para asegurar su supervivencia.
Muchos otros insectos anidan en heces.
Las moscas ponen sus huevos allí
y algunos escarabajos incluso
hacen grandes bolas de estiércol,
que luego comen
y usan para sus huevos.
Y luego está el gran poder
de la metamorfosis.
Este rasgo no solo transforma
a los insectos,
sino que les ayuda a optimizar los
recursos disponibles en un ecosistema.
Por ejemplo, las mariposas.
La oruga, durante su etapa larval,
devora vorazmente
y rápidamente el follaje,
lo que le ayuda crecer
y tejer capullos.
Pero al transformarse en mariposas,
estos insectos se alimentan
exclusivamente de néctar de flores.
La metamorfosis significa
que las larvas y los adultos
de la misma especie
nunca competirán por el mismo recurso,
y por eso se benefician
del mismo nicho ecológico
sin limitar su propio éxito.
Este proceso es tan eficaz
que un increíble 86 % de las especies
de insectos sufren metamorfosis completa.
Nosotros somos grandes
y ellos pequeños,
por eso es fácil olvidar
que hay millones de estos
bichos a nuestro alrededor,
todo el tiempo,
pero fíjate en cualquier rincón
y seguramente los verás allí.
Su número es muy elevado
y su éxito inigualable.
Tal vez deberíamos aceptar
que son los insectos,
no nosotros,
los verdaderos amos del planeta.